- Est-ce que tu sais
qu'il s'ouvre, lui?
- C'est déjà sa troisième
rentrée scolaire.
- Dès le début, on sait à peu
près à quoi notre année
va ressembler.
- Audrey Devost fait partie
de la première cohorte
d'un programme unique au Québec.
Elle suit ses cours
en enseignement préscolaire
et primaire deux jours
par semaine, à Sept-Îles.
AUDREY DEVOST, étudiante, Bacc.
en éducation, UQAC
- Les mardis et mercredis sont
réservés à l'université.
- Le reste de la semaine...
- Et ça, ce qui, lui?
- ... elle est en classe
etet enseigne.
- On est disponible les lundis,
les jeudis, les vendredis,
puis ça, jusqu'en juin, parce
qu'on a une session d'été aussi
qui commence en avril, donc
notre horaire est assez stable
toute l'année.
- Pendant son bacc., elle peut
recevoir jusqu'à 70 % du salaire
complet d'une enseignante.
- Moi, je trouve ça super bien
parce que ce qu'on apprend
à l'école, on peut rapidement
le mettre en pratique, donc
ce que les enseignants nous
enseignent, c'est plus concret,
c'est plus significatif.
- Ils sont une vingtaine
d'étudiants comme Audrey
à enseigner sur la Côte-Nord
en cette rentrée scolaire.
Parfois titulaires, mais plus
souvent en appui à un autre
enseignant.
RICHARD POIRIER, dir. général,
Centre de services scolaire, Fer
- Si on n'avait pas
ce programme-là, localement,
je vous dirais qu'on aurai
énormément de difficulté
à se trouver des enseignants.
- Richard Poirier dirige
le Centre de services scolaire
du Fer, où, cet automne, chaque
classe a son ensgngnant. Parmi
les 23 qui ne sont pas encore
diplômés, la majorité sont déjà
inscrits au programme.
- On dessert aussi des élèves
qui sont à Havre-Saint-Pierre,
qui so  à Fermont. Donc, là,
on a la chance d'avoir des gens
qui se forment, qui sont chez
nous et en plus, qui prennent
de l'expérience.
- En stage dans la même école,
Tania suit la même formation
qu'Audrey.
TANIA GUILLEMETTE, étudiante,
Bacc. en éducation, UQAC
- État maman de deux enfants,
quitter la région, pour moi,
c'était difficile. Donc,
j'ai sauté sur l'occasion.
C'était parfait pour moi,
la conciliation travail-famille.
Oh, une clémentine!
C'est très exigeant,
c'est trois cours par session,
plus notre travail, plus la vie
qui continue à côté de ça, donc,
oui, il faut prêt à donner
du temps.
- Donc, c'est deux travaux
séparés...
- Ces étudiants viennent
de commencer le même programmee.
- La planification étant
un peu le nerf de la guerre
dans l'enseignement...
- L'Université du Québ
à Chicoutimi, qui offre
la formation à Sept-Îles,
aura donc dû attendre trois ans
pour avoir les inscriptions
suffisantes afin de former
une deuxièmeohohorte,
la COVID n'aidant pas.
JOANIE DESGAGNÉ, professeure,
Baccalauréat en éducation, UQAC
- C'est pour ça aussi que
l'université existe, c'est pour
répondre aux besoins sociétaux.
On voit que c'est un bon
arrimage entre le travail
et les études. Je pense que
les étudiantes resntntent aussi
le fait que la formation est
adaptée à leurs besoins.
- Ce programme est-il
une solution à la pénurie
d'enseignants? De passage
sur la Côte-Nord, la présidente
de la Fédération des syndicats
d'enseignement a émis
ces conditions :
- Il faut que ces gens-là soient
accompagnés, ne soient pas
laissés à eux seuls.
- Mais l'initiative,
ajoute-t-elle, est très bonne.
JOSÉE SCALABRINI, prés., Féd.
syndicats d'enseignement (CSQ)
- Si on est capable de trouver
des solutions locales qui
viennent aider à une pénurie
locale, on peut pas se permettre
de mettre ça de côté.
Est-ce que c'est le besoin
partout au Québec?
Je le sais pas, il faudra mieux
le faire connaître, il faudra
le regarder.
- Ça t'intéresse pas?
- Tania et Audrey obtiendront
leur diplôme en 2024.
Déterminées à faire
leur carrière chez elles
à Sept-Îles.
- C'est quelque chose que moi,
je voulais, donc, c'est vraiment
parfait pour moi.
- L'Université du Québec
à Chicoutimi en collaboration
avec l'Université du Qbebec
à Rimouski envisagent maintenant
d'étendre ce programme
dans toute la Côte-Nord, mais
aussi dans le Bas-Saint-Laurent,
en Gaspésie
et aux Îledede-la-Madeleine.
Ils espèrent pouvoir former
une nouvelle cohorte d'étudiants
enseignants chaque année
à partir de l'an prochain.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Rioio-Canada, Sept-Îles.